Non mais là, on a un problème.
Vous savez que c’est une obligation légale d’aller à la police quand on a un cadavre sur les bras ?
Bah c’est qu’il y a de la place dans le congel. On a qu’à la mettre là-dedans en attendant.
Regarde Glitch, elle est juste là Shirley en fait.
Je l’ai croisé tout à l’heure avec un énorme steak dans la bouche. Il n’avait pas l’air malheureux.
Nan mais sérieux, vous pensiez que j’allais comprendre ça avec vos symboles à la con ?
OH !
En principe, si vous avez su trouver le chemin jusqu’à cette vidéo YouTube,
c’est que vous avez moins de 45 ans et que vous avez entendu parler de smileys, ou de frimousse en bon français.
La Commission d'enrichissement de la langue française recommande le terme “frimousse”.
Et l’Office Quebecois de la Langue Française le terme “binette”.
Voilà.
Dans un message, association facétieuse de quelques caractères typographiques qui évoquent un visage expressif.
Mais c’est quoi un smiley du coup, hein ? Parce que voilà,
on n’est pas plus avancé.
A l’origine, ce terme désigne l’association de lettres ou de symboles visant à dessiner à sourire,
comme le traditionnel deux-points-tiret-parenthèse-fermée (:-)),
mais son usage s’est étendu aux différents moyens de communiquer des émotions en détournant l’usage des caractères de votre clavier.
Aujourd’hui, on peut constater que ce terme s’est étendu pour se confondre alors avec celui d’émoticône,
qui était celui qui était consacré pour cette définition plus large.
A savoir que le terme emoji est un emprunt au japonais strictement synonyme au terme émoticône.
Donc pour résumer : le smiley est à l’origine le nom de l’émoticône qui illustre un sourire.
Mais aujourd’hui, ce terme est souvent utilisé pour désigner tout type d’émoticône à base de visages, si ce n’est tout type d’émoticône tout court.
Alors ça n’aura échappé à personne, l’usage du smiley s’est surtout imposé avec internet et la téléphonie mobile, donc fin des années 90 début des années 2000.
C’est alors surtout associé aux SMS à la base, et donc au langage SMS, que l’on a fustigé pour tout comme vous le savez surement,
mais je vous rassure utiliser des abréviations ou des petites têtes marrantes ne rend ni débile, ni illettré.
C’est pas le sujet ici donc je vais pas épiloguer,
mais non le langage SMS ne signe ni la fin de notre belle civilisation française,
ni une rupture dans l’histoire de la maitrise du code écrit. Voilà, c’est dit.
Le smiley exploite donc à l’origine les caractères disponibles sur un clavier de téléphone,
et si ce sont les smileys historiques qui restent en vogue,
leur usage s’est diversifié avec le temps.
D’ailleurs, vous l’ignoriez peut-être, mais il existe deux grandes familles de smileys.
Les occidentaux et les orientaux.
Les premiers étant à 90° et focalisés sur la bouche, c’est ceux qu’on trouve historiquement en Europe,
et les seconds étant horizontaux et focalisés sur les yeux, c’est ceux qu’on trouve historiquement au Japon,
et que l’on nomme kaomoji 顔文字.
Deux point tiret parenthèse ouverte :-) équivaut alors à parenthèse chapeau tiret-du-8 chapeau parenthèse (^_^),
deux point apostrophe parenthèse fermée :'( équivaut à T-majuscule tiret-du-8 T-majuscule.  T_T
Bon, j’vais faire toute la liste non plus hein. Surtout que tous n’ont pas d‘équivalents.
Si vous vous demandez comment ça se passe ailleurs dans le monde,
sachez en tout cas qu’en Corée du sud et en Chine, qui ont chacun un système d’écriture propre,
le système horizontal domine aussi.
La plus grande diversité et la plus grande expressivité se trouve certainement dans ce type,
qui aujourd’hui exploite parfois au maximum la diversité des caractères informatiques, mêlant plusieurs systèmes d’écriture.
Celui-ci par exemple ٩(͡๏̯͡๏)۶ exploite le :
chiffre 9 arabe, ( parenthèse ouverte, ๏ ponctuation Thaï, le symbole phonétique de la brève renversée souscrire notant un son non-syllabique,
le symbole phonétique de ligature tirante souscrit, ) une parenthèse fermée, ۶ et le chiffre arabo-perse 6
C’est pas simple. C’est pas simple.
Les smileys ont participé au renouvellement de la manière de communiquer.
En bouleversant la frontière entre l'oral et l’écrit,
et ils se sont particulièrement bien imposé sur internet que Jacques Anis définit comme l’endroit du “parlécrit”, l’endroit où le registre du parler et de l’écrit se sont mélangés.
Mais pourquoi donc ? mais comment donc me direz-vous.
Avec l’arrivée des moyens de communications écrits synchrones, c’est-à-dire de conversation en direct par le texte finalement,
comme MSN, ICQ, IRC, skype ou les chatroom de skyrock.
Parce que oui, je suis aussi vieux que ça.
ASV. 28, homme, Torcenay dans le 52.
Il demeure toujours que l’on ne parle pas comme l’on écrit,
on a développé un code spécifique au “parlécrit” justement.
On a plaqué de l’oral sur du texte, des interactions spontanées sur un mode d’expression qui en principe ne le demandait pas jusque-là.
Le smiley alors est utile puisqu’il occupe deux fonctions.
Il permet d’éviter les malaises et les malentendus en associant une émotion à un message afin de préciser l’intention avec lequel il est formulé,
et il permet également de relancer ou poursuivre une conversation.
Parce qu’il véhicule une émotion, l’usage des smileys est d’autant plus important entre deux personnes si elles sont proches,
et ils sont particulièrement bienvenues pour dédramatiser ou faciliter la discussion autour des sujets graves ou difficiles.
Mais si les smileys viennent lever des doutes sur nos intentions lorsque l’on communique à l’écrit, ils peuvent également en créer.
Tu sais que les emojis, ça peut être super intéressant.
Au tribunal, comment tu interprètes un pistolet que tu envoies à quelqu’un ?
En France, quelqu’un a envoyé un pistolet à son ex-copine, il avait aussi fait des menaces de mort,
et on a reconnu que le pistolet en lui-même, c’était aussi une preuve qu’il y avait bien une menace de mort sur sa meuf.
Ah oui quand même.
C’est vachement intéressant. Après, en France, on n’a pas trop de cas, c’est surtout aux États-Unis où ça commence à se développer.
Mais je pense qu’en France, on arrivera tôt ou tard à la même décision.
Tu vois, je me demande si par exemple, si tu envoies tout le temps à ton salarié ou une fille, les pêches et les aubergines et tout ça,
on sait que c’est un peu connoté quand même.
Est-ce que ça pourrait être considéré comme du harcèlement sexuel ?
La question, elle se pose. Cela pourrait être intéressant de reconnaître justement que ça peut être une preuve en elle-même.
Après, si on envoie juste l’emoji pêche et aubergine
je ne sais pas si ça suffira. Mais on va utiliser les emojis pour accréditer la thèse qu’on défend : le harcèlement sexuel.
Le contexte est important. Si jamais j’envoie juste une tête de mort ou la tête d’un mec mort, ce sera peut-être pas suffisant.
Ca va être un peu compliqué. On pourrait dire que tu as rippé par exemple. Et que tu ne le pensais pas.
Alors que si tu as envoyé des messages avant qui était un peu menaçant et qu’ensuite plus tard, tu envoies une tête de mort.
Oui, le contexte est vraiment important.
L’emoji va soutenir la thèse qui est tenue.
D’accord, parce qu’on considère qu’il apporte une information subjective en plus.
Ça dépendra du juge. Mais ouais, moi, ça ne me semble pas déconnant.
Ok. Non mais c’est intéressant les trucs de droit des fois.
En augmentant le nombre et la variété des smileys, la question de leur traduction se pose alors de plus en plus.
Viennent-ils communiquer une émotion, remplacent-ils un mot, se substituent-ils à une phrase ?
Cette simple question trahit le véritable rôle du smiley.
Ils sont probablement à l’écrit ce que sont les interjections à l’oral.
Mais c’est quoi une interjection, me direz-vous.
Eh bien, je vous répondrez mes amis, c’est les mots dont on ne sait pas trop quoi faire et que l’on dénigre souvent un peu trop vite.
Vous connaissez peut-être les noms, les adjectifs, les adverbes, les verbes d’un côté, et les prépositions, les conjonctions, les articles et les pronoms de l’autre.
C’est ce qu’on appelle des classes grammaticales.
Celles qui sont à gauche sont dites lexicales,
c’est les mots qui désignent des trucs dans la vraie vie,
et celles de droites sont dites grammaticales, c’est les mots outils dont on a besoin pour faire des phrases qui ont du sens.
Il se trouve qu’en réalité, il existe une autre classe de mot,
une classe oubliée et qui longtemps est restée inétudiée par la linguistique.
Cette classe, vous l’avez deviné, c’est celle des interjections.
Les interjections sont des mots ou groupe de mots invariables, qui fonctionnent indépendamment et dont le rôle primaire est purement émotionnel.
Elles sont universelles, présentes dans toutes les langues du monde, et elles possèdent un rôle communicatif très important à l’oral.
Les sons que vous émettez quand vous hésitez,
quand vous riez,
quand vous êtes surpris,
quand vous vous cognez…
Tout ça, ce sont des interjections.
Des interjections primaires mêmes, pour être précis.
Les interjections secondaires, c’est quand vous plaquez des mots sur ces émotions, comme “putain” ou “bordel de merde”.
A l’oral, même si vous ne faites pas attention, elles sont prédominantes et apportent du contexte à votre propos, des informations à la bonne compréhension de votre message.
Tout comme les smileys, les interjections ne sont pas présentes à l’écrit ou alors très rarement.
même dans les retranscriptions d’interviews, qui sont pourtant des échanges oraux par nature,
toute interjection sera gommée sauf lorsqu’il s’agira éventuellement d’insister sur le côté populaire de la personne interviewée.
Ce n’est en tout cas jamais pour servir son propos, c’est uniquement pour dire quelque chose de sa personnalité.
Si vous voulez montrer l’allure timide ou hésitante de votre interlocuteur,
vous transcrivez quelques “euh” suivis de trois petits points (euh…),
si au contraire vous voulez le montrer comme confiant ou sûr de lui, vous vous abstenez.
De manière générale, les interjections sont chassées lorsqu’il s’agit de “bien écrire” ou “d’écrire sérieusement”.
Vous ne verrez jamais de ahahah dans un texte de littérature ayant eu le Goncourt,
pas plus que vous ne verrez de smileys dans un article du figaro. C’est aussi vrai pour la littérature scientifique d’ailleurs.
Maintenant que tu le dis, c’est vrai que je n’ai jamais vu d’emoji dans des articles scientifiques ou des articles de presse.
Y a un endroit où les médias se servent des emojis, c’est sur les réseaux sociaux. C’est plutôt les community manager qui s’en servent.
Eux, ils se servent des emojis, soit pour donner du contexte aux articles qu’ils partagent, soit pour donner le thème général.
Peut-être dans certains médias qui essaient de faire un peu jeune, de casser les codes, ils peuvent utiliser des emojis ou des memes dans leurs articles.
Mais c’est hyper connoté, tu ne verras pas ça dans des magazines hyper sérieux, pour des gens d’un âge mûr.
C’est vraiment pour faire jeune quoi.
Pour que le web ait pu s’installer comme une norme dans les médias,
ça a mis beaucoup de temps.
Pareil pour les vidéos, ça fait quelques années que ça commence à être un peu la norme
dans les médias qui ont un peu de moyens.
Les emojis, à mon avis, ce n’est pas pour tout de suite.
Donc, c’est pas tout de suite que dans le 13h, on a une petite pêche ou des petites gouttes.
“XD Regardez ce reportage en Lozère”
En comparant le smiley aux interjections, j’ai omis une différence de taille.
Si vous pouvez difficilement vous retenir de vocaliser certaines interjections dans le cadre d’une conversation orale,
vous pouvez choisir vos smileys.
Quitte à ralentir le rythme de la conversation,
ou faire genre que vous n'aviez pas vu le message pour bien faire mûrir votre choix, parce qu'on connait les techniques, vous allez pas me la faire.
On peut donc légitimement se poser cette question :
les smileys sont-ils honnêtes ?
Eh bah… pas vraiment. Pas tout à fait. C’est compliqué.
Si les smileys ont contribué à bouleverser la frontière entre l’écrit et l’oral,
ils ont aussi bouleverser la frontière entre le contrôlable et le non-contrôlable.
Là où vous enverriez une bonne partie de signaux inconscients et spontanés à l’oral, vous pouvez les rationaliser lorsque vous utilisez une messagerie instantanée et ainsi augmenter votre marge de manœuvre.
Les smileys permettent de contrôler l’image que l’on souhaite renvoyer.
Communiquer des émotions qui ne sont pas celles que l’on a dans les faits, mais celles que l’on pense les meilleures dans tel ou tel cas, vis à vis de telle personne.
La seule partie incontrôlable qui demeure, c’est l’interprétation de ces smileys de la part de votre interlocuteur.
Cependant, il n’est pas impossible que la création d’habitude et la rapidité d’utilisation des plateformes de messagerie conduisent à une certaine forme de spontanéité,
qui cependant ne rivaliseront jamais avec celle de l’oral.
Il est possible aussi que l’habitude des pratiques au sein d’un même groupe social puisse y conduire.
Désormais, le smiley s’est bien imposé dans notre société. Il existe désormais une table unicode réservée aux smileys.
Certains d’entre eux sont donc informatiquement parlant strictement équivalents à n’importe quel caractère, que ce soit la lettre R, le point-virgule ou même le chiffre 4.
Désormais, la plupart des applications qui servent de messagerie instantanée, comme Instagram, twitter ou facebook, utilisent peu ou prou les mêmes dessins.
Et comme c’est le cas pour les mots, certains ont évolué en usage et en sens.
En fait, c’est même l’usage qui dicte strictement tout,
il n’existe aucune norme prééxistante à leurs significations.
C’est le cas de l’aubergine, par exemple, qui désigne désormais le pénis.
Ce détournement sémantique ne fut pas au goût d’instagram d’ailleurs, qui avait bloqué le pauvre légume dans ses recherches.
Une levée de bouclier avait eu lieu sur twitter avec le hashtag #freetheeggplant, un moyen pour quelques enseignes de grande distribution de gratter un peu de visibilité au passage.
Il y a quelques mois, facebook est allé dans la même direction en proscrivant dans certains cas l’usage des émoticônes à caractère sexuel,
à savoir l’aubergine, la pêche et les goutte d’eau. Le penis, la vulve, l’éjaculat. Si vous avez besoin d’une traduction.
Facebook motive ce choix par son besoin de lutter contre la prostitution sur le réseau social et contre « le contenu [qui] facilite, encourage ou coordonne les rencontres sexuelles entre adultes ».
Ce qu’il y a de fascinant, c’est que ces symboles s’imposent comme des idéogrammes compris et partagés par des gens parlant plusieurs langues différentes.
On peut convertir des mots en symboles sans passer l’écriture alphabétique, et on peut donc contourner la barrière de la langue.
Je n’ai pas besoin de comprendre le tchèque si je vois dans un tweet aubergine-goutte-d’eau au milieu du texte.
Donc, pénis-éjaculat, si vous n’avez pas suivi.
Ça marche avec d’autres émoticônes hein.
C’était juste que là on était dans le thème.
Notons cependant que parfois, la signification d’un émoticône est cloisonné à un espace culturel.
Lorsque que la main pincée en l’air est apparue, tout le monde dans le monde occidental y a vu un symbole italien, et c’était sa fonction dédiée d’ailleurs.
Mais en Inde ce geste sert à demander à quelqu’un s’il a faim,
dans le monde arabe il sert à appeler au calme,
et dans certaines communautés BDSM… c’est un geste pour le fistfucking.
Alors Monté, je t’ai fait une petite présa sur les emojis dans le marketing, les pubs tout ça.
Oui, je vois ça. T’étais pas obligé hein.
En fait, en gros pour moi, l’utilisation des emojis dans la comm, elle tient pour plusieurs raisons.
Ça intéresse beaucoup les marketeux tout ce qui concerne comment on va impacter le consommateur et comment on va faire en sorte qu’il mémorise le truc.
Et clairement, les emojis, c’est hyper visuel, et donc ça marche toujours mieux qu’un discours ou du texte
pour impacter visuellement ou faire en sorte que la personne va retenir l’information.
À côté de ça, ça transmet des émotions.
Qui dit émotion dit engagement, ça c’est un truc qui est vachement recherché par les marques. C’est d’associer des émotions à leurs produits.
Et en mettant des emojis dans ta comm, t’associes des émotions et tu augmentes l’engagement des consommateurs envers la marque.
Et ce qui est cool aussi, c’est que toutes ces émotions et tout ce qu’on veut communiquer autour d’un produit au consommateur, avec des emojis, tu es universel. Tu peux t’adresser un peu à toutes les langues.
C’est vraiment idéal pour faire des campagnes internationales.
D’accord, je te donne un 12/20.
Ah, je m’en vais du coup ?
- Oui, tu te barres.
- Je me barre OK.
Les années 60 ou 70, ce serait donc le début des smileys.
Pourtant, ils ne datent pas vraiment non plus de ce moment là.
Pas du tout même.
Si France soir est souvent considéré comme le premier journal à en faire usage, ce serait oublier ce journal du 2 septembre 1893 de Rhénanie Prussienne, en Allemagne,
ou encore dans cette publicité du 10 mars 1953 du New York Herald Tribune.
Tribune... Tribune...
Yes !
On pourrait aussi parler de la signature de cet abbé en 1741, ou même de ce vase hittite du 1e millénaire avant notre ère.
Eh oui, si vous pensiez que nos aïeux étaient bien plus sérieux à l’écrit de nous autres, leur pauvre descendance en déshérence, vous vous trompez.
Par ailleurs, des personnalités dont on dirait volontiers que leur travail est très sérieux s’y sont intéressées.
C’est le cas du philosophe Ludwig Wittgenstein, qui en parle dans ses cours à Cambridge en 1938.
Dans les notes qui en sont tirées puis publiées, on trouve 3 smileys et une réflexion générale sur leur utilisation.
Bien avant l’ère d’internet Wittgenstein considère que le smiley est bien plus précis et flexible pour retranscrire une émotion qu’un simple adjectif.
Aujourd’hui, le smiley est incontournable.
Décliné sous diverses sortes, accompagné d’autres emojis ou émoticônes toujours plus imagées et précises, dont le sens est libre ou bien arbitraire,
il a cassé le monopole du texte pur.
Le gif animé n’est que la continuité du smiley.
Si aujourd’hui nous avons beaucoup de gifs tirés de films, de vidéos youtube, de programmes télés ou de vidéos cultes du net en général,
cette utilisation était très limitée à l’époque,
si ce n’est inexistante, tout simplement car nous n’avions pas tous le débit nécessaire à leur affichage.
Moi j’ai eu internet genre en 2005,
on voyait charger les images en direct. Alors les vidéos… fallait se lever de bonne heure.
Ce format a historiquement beaucoup servi pour les smileys animés,
puisqu’il permettait d’afficher des versions animées très légères car composées de très peu de couleurs.
Sur MSN ou sur les chatroom, ils étaient légions.
Si vous aussi vous êtes nostalgique de cette belle époque des années 2000,
Sobri, Leslie, Amine, tout ça…
et bien n’hésitez pas à venir en parler sur le Discord du Vortex. Le lien est en description,
en attendant, vous pouvez liker, commenter, partager, mettre la cloche et y a quoi d’autre… vous abonner. Euh voilà.
C’est comme ça que j’aurais dû répondre tout à l'heure à vos smileys. Avec un gif.
Ca, au moins, tout le monde comprend, c’est moins figuratif.
T’es sérieux ? Tu viens de m’envoyer un gif d’enterrement ?
Si ça vous dérange pas, on pourrait l’enterrer pour de vrai ce coup-là.
On vote ?
Non, on vote pas ! Non.
T’inquiète pas Valentine. On va essayer de bien s’en occuper. Pour passer à autre chose. Et c’est comme ça et pas autrement.
Elle veut qu’on passe chez le fleuriste aussi ?
Bon, on vous a déjà expliqué la vidéo d'avant et la vidéo encore d'avant...
Donc... bon...
On va en remettre une couche, mais actuellement en direct sur Twitch.
sur ma chaine.
Vous pouvez venir parler du sujet, si vous voulez.
Si vous ne voulez pas venir en parler, vous pouvez venir écouter, ça mange pas de pain.
Et puis c'est déjà pas mal. Voilà.
Donc viendez.
Viendez, viendez tous.
Et, on vous attend quoi. Maintenant.